Dresden an der Elbe.
Historische Bauten aus Renaissance,
Barock und aus dem 19. Jahrhundert
prägen das Stadtbild.
Wegen seiner prächtigen Architektur, die
sich an italienischer Baukunst orientierte,
wird Dresden auch als
„Elb-Florenz“ bezeichnet.
Dresden hat eine wunderbare Altstadt
mit verschiedensten tollen Museen,
die zu den weltbekanntesten
Sammlungen gehören,
die in den Staatlichen
Kunstsammlungen ihr Zuhause haben.
Eine tolle Oper mit der Semperoper.
Die Semperoper am Theaterplatz ist
das musikalische Wahrzeichen der Stadt.
Das Bauwerk wurde nach Plänen
des deutschen Baumeisters
Gottfried Semper errichtet.
Nur rund 650 Meter entfernt steht
Dresdens berühmtestes Wahrzeichen:
die Frauenkirche.
Im Zweiten Weltkrieg
1945 komplett zerstört,
wurde sie durch ihren Wiederaufbau ein
Symbol für Frieden und Versöhnung.
Der Kunsthistoriker Claus Kemmer
erklärt Besuchern die Stadt.
Die Frauenkirche kann man
im Grunde genommen
als das Zentrum der Stadt
eigentlich betrachten.
Also, dass mit ihr wirklich der,
ja, der Aufstieg Dresdens
ja von dieser kriegszerstörten Stadt
zu einer neuen Metropole
eigentlich verbunden ist.
Unweit der Frauenkirche zeigt
der sogenannte „Fürstenzug“
Sachsens Könige und Kurfürsten,
darunter Dresdens berühmtester
Herrscher: August der Starke.
Ihm hat die Stadt eine
umfangreiche Kunstsammlung
und zahlreiche Prachtbauten
zu verdanken,
etwa den Zwinger.
Das Bauwerk ist einem römischen
Amphitheater nachempfunden.
Beim Zwinger sind wir wirklich in
der Glanzzeit Dresdens angekommen:
im 18. Jahrhundert.
Das ist die Zeit von August dem Starken,
der nicht nur Kurfürst Sachsens war,
sondern König von Polen.
Und der hat den Zwinger bauen lassen
als einen prächtigen Raum eigentlich,
wo er sich selbst inszenieren
konnte in großen Festlichkeiten.
Im Zwinger sind auch
Museen untergebracht,
darunter die Gemäldegalerie „Alte Meister“.
Die Sammlung beinhaltet
rund 3.000 Kunstwerke,
darunter Schätze wie die
Sixtinische Madonna von Raffael
- ein Meisterwerk der
italienischen Renaissance.
Dresden hat viele sehenswerte Museen.
Dazu zählt auch das „Albertinum“.
Hier sind Gegenwartskunst und eine
bedeutende Skulpturensammlung zu sehen.
Gleich gegenüber:
die Kunsthalle im Lipsiusbau
mit ständig wechselnden Ausstellungen.
Aktuell werden flämische Landschaften
von Bruegel bis Rubens gezeigt.
Die Stadt Dresden beherbergt ja eine der
ältesten und umfassendsten Sammlungen
an Kunst überhaupt, der italienischen,
niederländischen, französischen,
deutschen und spanischen Malerei
seit dem 16. Jahrhundert.
Ein spannender Kontrast zu all
der Pracht: Dresdens Äußere Neustadt.
In dem Szeneviertel gibt es
viele Cafés, Design-Manufakturen,
Clubs und Galerien - wie hier in der
Kunsthofpassage mit ihren Hinterhöfen.
Die äußere Neustadt war eigentlich
immer schon ein Viertel für kleine Leute,
sag‘ ich mal, einfache kleine Wohnungen.
Es gab auch günstige Mieten.
Und das hat ganz viele Studenten
angezogen, junge kreative Leute.
Die sind dorthin gegangen, die wollten
nicht im Plattenbauviertel leben.
In der Innenstadt gab‘s keine
Wohnungen, und dann ist da
dieses Kneipen-und Szeneviertel
dann eigentlich entstanden.
Ein neuer Anziehungspunkt für
Kulturliebhaber und Kreative
soll das ehemalige Heizkraftwerk
im Stadtzentrum werden.
Eröffnung ist im Dezember.
Wo einst Wärme und
Strom produziert wurden,
stehen bald Kunst und
Kultur im Mittelpunkt.
Unter anderem bekommt hier Dresdens
Staatsoperette einen neuen Spielort.
Für die Stadt Dresden ist Musik natürlich
schon immer besonders wichtig gewesen.
In der monarchistischen Zeit war
das schon eine Musikmetropole,
und das war natürlich aber
auch in der ganzen bürgerlichen
und protestantischen Zeit
eine große Musikmetropole.
Dresden - eine wahre
Schatzkammer an der Elbe.